-Hi, buddy. How are you?
-I'm good. How's it going?
-I'm doing really well.
Hey, congratulations
on this movie.
As you know, I love it.
-Well, thank you very much.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, look at that.
You have the mug.
-Oh!
This is your show!
I use it so much, I forgot
it even has anything
to do with you.
-Oh, that's so kind of you,
Andy.
I wish I had -- you know,
they actually did send some swag
from your movie "Palm Springs."
I'm going to prove
this is not planned
because otherwise I would
have had it, but...
-I can just talk to the sea
captain while you're gone.
Hey, man.
-Look, this is a for-real thing
that showed up.
-Oh, nice! Yeah. From the movie.
-Yeah.
It's a blow-up piece of pizza.
And it actually says
"as seen in the Hulu original
film 'Palm Springs.'"
-It's easy to do promos
like that when your props
cost very, very little money.
-So you obviously did not
film this movie
thinking it would only
be available on Hulu
because it was made
in a different time.
-Correct, pre-COVID.
-It actually is
a pretty good movie
for the times we're living in,
though.
I mean, it's super funny,
but it's also, like,
really thoughtful
and lovely performances
from you and Cristin.
But it's a good -- it's a "good
times we're living in" movie.
-It definitely makes you think
about what it's like
when you're forced to sit with
yourself and face who you are.
And, you know,
there's a cyclical nature
to the lives we are
living right now.
-Yes. This is another -- a film
about a guy who might not know
exactly how much time
has passed,
which I think we all
are right now.
-Yes. I also just want to
quickly say
I got the memo
that we should dress identical.
And thank you for sending that.
-Of course.
You're very welcome.
-I want to confuse people
as much as possible
watching as to who is who.
-Yeah.
I think that's really good.
I think ultimately we probably
won't do this with sound.
So it'll just --
it'll just be --
-Oh, great.
-Hey, you know, again,
I really love the film.
I took to Instagram to say it,
and I apologize that my dog --
obviously, anyone who knows you
and I know that you're not a fan
of my dog Frisbee.
-Right.
-And basically my Instagram post
was that Frisbee had no interest
in seeing "Palm Springs"
and said she would prefer to put
her nose close to her butthole.
-Right. I mean, I saw the post,
and I want to say, first off,
thank you for the kind words
about the movie.
-Yeah.
-And, second, it was actually
an interesting thing
because when I saw the post,
the picture of Frisbee --
there was a moment
when I first saw it
where I was, like, "Oh, yes!"
Because in the picture,
it almost looks like Frisbee
is dead, you know?
-Uh-huh.
-Has passed on.
-Yeah.
-And is no longer with us.
-Uh-huh.
-Which, to me was, like,
"Whoa, Seth liked the movie,
and the rat is dead."
-Oh, so, like, for you
it was a win-win?
-It was jubilation.
[ Laughter ]
But then I read the caption
and I realized
it was kind of a burn,
and I was like...
-Right.
-"That's funny, but I wish
Frisbee was dead."
-You really take advantage of
this opportunity
like when you're on the show.
You are in the safety of
a television studio.
And you've laid into Frisbee
pretty hard over the years.
-That's true.
-Yeah.
So I guess if you would just
bear with me for a second.
-Sure.
Sea Captain.
-You know, 'cause we're doing it
from home now, Samberg.
-Sea Captain, are you --
-And, like, would you say it
to her face?
-Look.
-Look how much she hates you.
Look how much.
She hates you so much.
-Frisbee, I just want to say
it's all in good fun.
You're a good dog.
-Okay.
-Like, it's --
You can't listen to Seth.
Don't look at the screen,
Frisbee.
-How did you have that ready?
-I was going to do it
no matter what!
Frisbee sucks, dude!
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, Frisbee, I'm going to
let you go, girl.
Don't come back until you have
tonight's pheasants for dinner.
-I'm actually kind of
lightheaded now.
I hate confrontation.
-[ Laughs ]
You did really well.
-Thank you.
-I thought you did really well.
You are a very -- I've said --
yeah, thank you.
You were a great actor always.
You're particularly good
in this film.
-Thank you.
-And it should be noted
that Cristin Milioti
is a wonderful co-star.
The two of you were great.
-She's actually good.
-Did you ever feel like at "SNL"
you had a scene where you
thought, "Oh, I'm a good actor"?
-You know, I never felt it
deep down personally,
but I will say this.
There was a sketch
when Galifianakis hosted
where I was the straight man
in it.
And afterwards a lot of people
at the show --
like, writers
and casts and people
who worked at the show
were like,
"Hey, man, you were really good
in that.
You really grounded it."
And the sketch was called
"Bidet."
-[ Laughs ]
I remember "Bidet."
-It was a sketch where Zach
and Wiig are at a --
I'm showing them around a hotel.
I'm, like, the fancy bell boy,
and they just keep asking
questions about the bidet.
They're like,
"And what about the bidet?
Does it have a sturdiness
to it?"
[ Laughter ]
And I guess good acting
in this context
was just not laughing
because I really did want to.